io delle donne non sopporto che dicono
che non si mostravano mari ciao ragazzi
bentornati una nuova puntata di vita
buttata il tema della puntata di oggi è
maschi contro femmine non è un pò stessi
st femmine contro maschi che comunque se
esista il tema della bruciatura di oggi
contro un anno fa all'università di
cambridge ha fatto lo studio più grande
che sia mai stato fatto su questo tipo
di tema studiando 670 mila persone per
giungere alla conclusione ossia che le
donne effettivamente tendono ad avere un
cervello più impatti con gli uomini un
cervello più sistematico dicendo che
effettivamente ci sono delle differenze
non sono al cento per cento d'accordo a
livello proprio di esperienza che io o
tu queste grandi differenze fra uomini e
donne
ma per farci una risata abbiamo comunque
chiesto di farci sapere quali sono
quelle cose che vi danno fastidio delle
altre persone ed è per questo anche che
ho deciso di invitare all'interno degli
studios the casa mia non una ma due
persone che tutti quanti dicono essere
le vere star di questo canale ho
accettato di fare un passo indietro ed è
per questo che vi presento oggi per la
prima volta una co conduzione tra mio
fratello enrico
e mia cugina la linea esposta
non vi dovete sentire osservati loro
dovranno ascoltare i commenti che
verranno fatti dalle persone e decidere
diciamo quali tesi sostenere abbiamo
diciamo se sosterrete gli uomini il papa
non stacchi sa che per essere dunque
paritari anche le donne ad ascoltare
assolutamente sì come si chiama buoni
amici di salvataggio ma uomini nel senso
di nome ciao ragazzi sono sempre che con
l'oro di cose che odio di altre donne ne
ho veramente tante primo fra tutti
quello nel ma lui non abbassa mai la
carica del eccesso quando vai in bagno
che abbasserà di scusa lui la decorsa la
bassi the equa distribuzione dei compiti
no evo distribuzione degli scorsi in
casa o ancora il classico se non mi
offri lui la cena allora io non gliela
do scusa che sta venda passerà ma la
figlia mia il femminismo esiste fatti
valere responsabilizzati ed equalizzato
mario bravo mandami a rischio proprio il
montaggio supporto chi manda incerto
perché mi disse tutto il genere maschile
ma soprattutto fa fare una brutta figura
a chi non lo fa quando scrivi da
qualcuno usate la testa non la testa del
fare un pacchettino e mandargli una
medaglia
non lo so non sono più esigenti ridammi
questo cosa devo dire una cosa
alla faccia di uno che lo manda no c'è
da dire che non c'è nulla di male
nell'inviare
ho una passerella diciamo che a mio
avviso non è proprio il più graditissimo
dei presenti così ha salutato così su
due piedi e quello sì ma adesso devo
fare quelli credo di fare ciao scusa
tranquillo a metà fastidio una cosa
uomini e tre donne ovvero sono i luoghi
comuni o una collega che tantissime e
non sai perché noi no non è poi dei ds
una ritardata attaccare bene il motivo
un mio amico
no perché saranno il card no ti piace va
bene
niente sono un po pazzo quindi ciò ha
detto una cosa molto sull coriano
riserve la penna ha detto che non ti
puoi nascondere dietro l'etichetta per
dire una cosa che in realtà è una sua
caratteristica anche io detesto le
generalizzazioni detesto i luoghi comuni
a sfondo sessuale barra sessista ma
ancor di più
sinceramente detesto le persone che
respirano e con una temperatura di 30
gradi sempre per sé ma che ci fa caso
tipo se ti offrono la cena se ti aprono
la porta hanno allora quando il giovane
in realtà si facevo molto caso
soprattutto perché comunque veniamo da
una famiglia in cui fortunatamente gli
uomini con tutti molto molto molto
galante diciamolo questo va detto poi
sono dei calzini misti all'impiego alla
causa e di tutto gli spiegherà cosa sia
un catino ma non lo sono e cioè che ogni
incrocio tra un ballo terme all'impiedi
è un delfino ruotando sei un dormiente
interviene ministero si fionda utenti
colma veronica
adesso invece ho capito che nonostante
secondo me la galanteria sia veramente
alla base di ogni tipologia del rapporto
adesso ho imparato che si fa quello che
si può
io offro sempre tutto io sono un tipico
dei film e ospiti con supporto delle
donne perché questo sentiero
sono attratta da un uomo e magari anno
con coraggio del processo però mi
conoscono tra quella stramaledetta frase
che io odio tu sei l'uomo deve fare il
primo passo in una società così evoluta
come dovrebbe essere oggi nel 2019
perché si pensa ancora avessero uomo
senza dover fare il primo passo
se si vuole il web tra i sessi se devo
dire in tutto in realtà è la donna fa
credere all'uomo di fare il primo passo
connettività perché la donna la
cacciatrice dell'uomo a bocca sempre
alla ma il cammino è diventato facile
una grazia questi su due ma l'ultimo 0 2
secondi è fermato ciao ciao che non
sopporto degli uomini il nostro porto le
mamme degli uomini che figli e li
trattano come se fossero dei principi
eco sistema che maturano da una toppa ai
50 anni e va bene io non ce l'ho per
niente con i bambini non ho avuto alcune
nostre
metteva la critica rivolta al genitore
non al figlio a meno che lo zio no non
l'ho mai cadere nel solito cliché ma
sembra dire settore quest'altro a
gridarmi sempre a reprimere la mia in
dalla stilista ma se proprio devo
parlare di quello che mi dà fastidio
nell'altro sesso band il fatto che
quando ricchi di come sta che dice bene
intanto brandisce un machete
insanguinato dito la schiena che
nasconde molto bene anche se in realtà
bove di questa punta insanguinata che è
lì lì per trafiggere è stato ammazzato
tutti i frequenti tesoro carissimo ma
nessuna donna di dirham bene ti diremo
mi è una cosa che non sopporto delle
donne perché parla la mattina la mattina
mi aspetta dormire bisogna odiare il
prossimo brava mattina pomeriggio e sera
intervenire io conosco un sacco di
uomini che sono super iperattiva ma e
inaugurò e e di donne che si sono
completamente morte io non voglio
comunicare con nessuno
personalmente e farle in qualità di
donne in questo momento io non voglio
comunicare con nessuno infatti ma di eni
a covare il tuo odio con noi che non ti
a chi dare intanto lo vedi che scorrazza
con la sua media avvolto precari la
mattina uno del se deve farsi
assolutamente anche vuol dire la mattina
doveva essere il sito fino a chi orario
check in e 18 e diventa quello di altri
12 e 30 direi può esserlo
anzi se già attivo felice vedi il mondo
meraviglioso a che livello per farlo non
importa quanti messaggi tu possa
maggiore op ragazzo lui risponderà
sempre e solo all'ultimo e soprattutto a
fronte del tuo panegirico risponderà
sempre solo io purtroppo non posso dire
niente
1 st porta parlare in veneto anche in
faccia soprattutto quando sono uomini ma
io lo trovo una cosa così carina invece
non c'e niente di più bello di una
persona che piange in generale che
dimostra di essere umana
le riviste le compri per la copertina
male butti da buongiorno cioè se vuoi
prendere per tutta la vita invece le
persone di un ottimo andare oltre la
prima pagina sbam
ma è arrivato ciao e non solo ma non hai
paura dei tuoi sentimenti cioè noi
viviamo dentro st società in cui è tutto
filtrato sotto instagram ato io adoro
invece le persone che si spera ci fa una
cosa del nord
non sopporto qui uomini dicono che le
donne siano impedendo a guidare ma chi
ve l'ha detto ma l'idea è tutto questo
contro mia testa contro il muro ok senza
in macchina si ciao ospita c'è una cosa
che non può portare le donne in
particolar modo della mia ragazza essere
sempre citando chiedendo d'amore a che
punto sei dice sono proprie
lo dice mentre corre tutta sudata in
intimo per casa e toccanti lo sono le
sedi che la persona più ritardatari del
mondo gabriele in luigi sono comunque
due uomini il tar natali saranno sempre
ritardatari uomini o donne che siano
bene di famiglia essere editato quindi
io impazzisco però quei ritardi cioè io
quando io su ad attirare sempre ritardo
ma io impazzisco finire il video
sempre queste intrusioni ritardatario
questo canale non è un albergo
fate ridere il pubblico ospite mastino
finto per me mattina finito ma niente
volevo farle tacere
siamo la forza di martin ha vinto io
voglio essere mar presentati cose che
non sopporto degli uomini omega che non
capisco è quando gli uomini si
abbracciano ed dopo che sono stretti in
un abbraccio si danno anche delle pacche
sulle spalle un forum perché hanno il
bisogno di farsi ma neanche come si
abbracciano non lo capisco perché così
non mostrano di essere troppo dolci
forse perché sono dei vigorosi re il
beach soccer sulla spalla tagliate le
regole ragazzi siamo arrivati alla fine
di questo video spero che questo
esperimento mi è piaciuto e soprattutto
vi ringrazio per i vostri commenti sono
contento contentissimo di avere persone
che parlano come esseri del presente del
2019 temevo che potessimo toccare
veramente il fondo in fondo è invece
questo fondo non è stato toccato al
grande questa logica rotondità avevamo
mostrato qual è il futuro abbiamo stato
tra il presente e questa cosa mi riempie
di orgoglio infatti un sorriso da qui a
cui come lo stregatto detto ciò
ringrazio enrico ringrazio la vigna per
la loro partecipazione mai fine
il regalino mi offendo anzi non mi
ringraziare ma prima grazie nessuno per
aver preso parte a questo video fatemi
sapere qua sotto se siete d'accordo con
quello che avete sentito se siete
accordo con gli grandi studi di
cambridge ma soprattutto fatemi sapere
quali sono le nostre esperienze come
sempre l'invito a iscrivervi attivare la
campanelline delle notifiche qua sotto
per un tender di i prossimi video detto
ciao ci vediamo il prossimo giovedì
sempre alle 14 con un nuovo vita buttata
ciao ciao ammazzano sul tufo malattia
non la fanno ciao zio
reg